buriatia feels like it's a world away
from war in Europe it is a different
Russia more like Mongolia next door than
Moscow
but drive a little way from the main
city of ulanude and you reach this
graveyard where the true cost of the war
is spelled out in funeral garlands and
Military flags and in the faces of men
all killed six time zones away in
Ukraine
blood is love cook Gordon
he was 20 years old and he died on the
second day of the war on the 25th of
February
Russia's been so
reluctant to talk about their casualties
and you don't see these kinds of scenes
on Russian State TV
but they're
have been so many kills
already in this one year of fighting and
it doesn't look like it's going to end
anytime soon
though the numbers are hard to verify
buriatia has one of the highest casualty
counts of any Russian region
not her real name has two nephews
fighting in Ukraine both try to
terminate their contracts she says and
they were turned down
um
do you feel that buratians have been
unfairly targeted to fight in this war
no yeah foreign
living standards are low here
unemployment is high an army contract is
Big Money
and nearly everyone has lost someone
um
foreign
used to attend the rally she could
against War then mobilization till they
were shut down 20
000 people detained in this one year of
War
why did you decide to speak out now
because this is dangerous for you
foreign
just what tomorrow brings another day in
the shadow of one man's War
Dana McNay Sky News Orlando day Russia